i spoke to you for the meg  you know how much i had so much fun with  that movie are you doing the sequel are  you involved in that  yeah we are we're gonna start shooting  in january uh if i get my dates right  um uh and ben wheatley is the director  uh i'm very excited to work with him um  um i'm thrilled to to get going you know  it's been a while  uh we've been waiting around for the  right scripts to come in and  the right director to turn up and we've  got all those things and they're all  stacked up now  yeah i spoke to ben recently for uh in  the earth and i told him  when i heard his name i was like are you  effing kidding me i can't wait  he's such a such an unusual and good  choice  yeah he's great we just we have a great  uh  a great short hand already you know  we've got we we've got cinemates  i like i like his movies i think he's a  brilliant director i think  i think we've got a good shot of making  something good